so yeah magnus uh could not really  convert what he had up he had a very  nice position up but up up until  a certain point but then  uh  he made a mistake and uh his opponent  managed to get out of the corner and  yeah in this position he just took a  repetition with bishop g3 bishop f2  yeah and this is the olympiad yeah that  if if uh as you mentioned yeah until  things work out in your favor everything  is fantastic yeah the team is driving  you and you get all this extra energy  but at the moment when suddenly  something happens with the team that the  team is disbalanced or somehow the  stability is lost and the result is not  coming then it can easily happen that  that suddenly nothing works anymore for  the team no matter how much they are  trying  yeah and uh satiris informs us that in  this game between magnus and uh  uh the these are the only two winners of  the greek great chess awards so far so  it's a very exclusive club and they were  contests